Millions of women are exploring what
it means to transition to natural hair.
We know that when Black women embracetheir love for their natural hair,
it helps to undo generations of teaching thatBlack in its natural state is not beautiful,
or something to be hidden or covered up.
Black women express their individuality
and experiencefeelings of empowerment
by experimenting
with different hairstyles regularly.
When we're invited to wear our
natural hair in the workplace,
it reinforcesthat we are uniquely valued.
So when you see a woman with braids
or locks draping down her back,
or younotice your colleague who has stopped straightening her hair to work,
really appreciate her.
This is more than abouta hairstyle.
It's about self-love and self-worth.